Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, a podcast from the American Psychological Association. I'm your host, Caitlin Luna. Today we're doing a bonus episode related to the college admissions bribery scandal that was exposed this week. This is the case in which prosecutors accused affluent parents of paying a consultant to get their children into prestigious universities by having someone else take their SATs or by fabricating athletic achievements. Our guest for this episode is Dr. Sunia Luther, Foundation Professor of Psychology at Arizona State University. She specializes in adolescent development, vulnerability and resilience in young people in poverty, as well as teens from upper middle class families. Dr. Luther was also featured in a 2014 episode of Speaking of Psychology called The Mental Price of Affluence. Thank you for joining us today, Dr. Luther. It's great to have you back on the show.
欢迎收听美国心理学会的播客《心理学谈话》。我是主持人凯特琳·卢纳。今天我们制作了一期特别节目，内容与本周曝光的大学招生贿赂丑闻有关。在这起案件中，检察官指控富裕的家长通过向顾问行贿，让孩子通过他人代考SAT或伪造体育成就的方式进入名牌大学。本期节目的嘉宾是亚利桑那州立大学心理学基金会教授苏尼亚·路德博士。她专门研究青少年发展、贫困青少年的脆弱性与韧性，以及中上层家庭的青少年。路德博士也曾出现在2014年《心理学谈话》的一期节目中，主题是《富裕带来的心理代价》。感谢您今天加入我们，路德博士。很高兴您能回到节目中。
It's my pleasure. So developing an identity and learning autonomy are crucial parts of growing up. And of course, parents can help their teens navigate the college application process, but teens really should have some level of control over it. So if a parent is basically doing everything to get their kid into a college, how does that affect their teen's self-esteem? Well, yes, I agree with you that adolescence is a time when kids should be developing a sense of autonomy, their own identity, and so on.
这是我的荣幸。建立自我认同和学习自主性是成长过程中至关重要的部分。当然，家长可以帮助青少年应对大学申请过程，但青少年确实应该对此拥有一定程度的控制权。那么，如果家长基本上包办了一切来让孩子进入大学，这会如何影响青少年的自尊心呢？嗯，是的，我同意你的观点，青春期是孩子们应该发展自主意识、自我认同感等的时期。
and in this current generation of youngsters, that is not the case for many of them who are aiming to get into the better colleges and schools. Having said that, I don't believe it's fair to put the blame squarely on the parents. Why do I say that? Because this pressure to get ahead doesn't come only from parents. People ask me, Professor Luther, where does this pressure come from? And my answer typically is, where does it not come from? It comes from parents.
而在当代年轻人中，许多以进入更好的大学和学校为目标的孩子并非如此。话虽如此，我不认为把责任完全归咎于家长是公平的。为什么这么说？因为这种追求领先的压力不仅仅来自家长。人们问我：“路德教授，这种压力从何而来？”我的回答通常是：“它哪里没有压力？”它来自家长。
It comes from teachers and coaches who want their kids to be, you know, one state levels and have all these accolades. It comes from peers. They compare notes with each other constantly. And it comes from kids themselves. So while I agree with you that young people, adolescents these days, in this demographic, particularly don't have that, who am I, the choice to say who am I, explore that sense of identity.
它来自那些希望孩子达到州级水平并获得各种荣誉的老师和教练。它来自同龄人。他们不断地互相比较。它也来自孩子们自己。所以，虽然我同意你的观点，即当今这个人口统计学群体中的年轻人、青少年确实没有那种“我是谁”的选择权，无法去探索那种自我认同感。
I don't believe it's the fault of the parents. I believe it's the fault of a system that is basically corraling the kids as a herd toward do everything you possibly can academically and in terms of extracurriculism. That is your job. That is who you are for all these years. And what is it doing to mental health of our teens today, children and teens? The toll this extracts on them is enormous. You know, people often speak about some people too about teenagers today being. overprotected and Molly coddled and such. Truthfully, my own take on this is that they're
我不认为这是家长的错。我认为这是一个系统的错，它基本上像赶牛群一样把孩子们赶向“在学术和课外活动方面尽你所能做到一切”。这就是你的工作。这就是你多年来所代表的一切。这对当今青少年、儿童和青少年的心理健康有什么影响？这给他们带来的代价是巨大的。你知道，人们经常谈论当今的青少年被过度保护、娇生惯养等等。老实说，我个人的看法是，他们
horrendously overworked, horrendously overworked. You know, we read about the lack of sleep and so on, the rates of depression, self-harm, tragically suicide, substance abuse. Our kids are under such enormous pressure and strain, even something that was, it used to be fun, like playing a sport, or playing a musical instrument. Even that now is pursued with grim determination as a means to an end. So they're, and very heavily scrutinized by an audience that is the entire school, parents or the entire community, local community. So the pressure of all of this is just so astronomical.
被极其沉重地过度劳累了，极其沉重地过度劳累了。你知道，我们读到关于睡眠不足等问题，抑郁、自残、悲剧性的自杀、药物滥用的比率。我们的孩子承受着如此巨大的压力和紧张，甚至连曾经是有趣的事情，比如参加体育运动或演奏乐器，现在也被以一种冷酷的决心作为达到目的的手段来追求。所以他们受到一个由整个学校、家长或整个当地社区组成的观众的严密审视。因此，这一切带来的压力简直是天文数字。
It is no wonder that our children are showing such high and increasing levels of depression, anxiety and substance use. Let me add one more thing. There was an article that just was published, I think, yesterday, the day before in the Journal of Abnormal Psychology on trends of increasing depression over time. And while there have been increases in all social demographic groups, I understand that the steepest gains, the steepest rises, increases have been among the highest income level youth. In other words, the teenagers from the most affluent families are the ones who show the steepest rises in levels of depressive symptoms over time. So this is not something we're imagining. That is one set of findings. Another one is a report issued by the Robert Wood Johnson Foundation, where they listed the top four environments that sort of jeopardize adolescent well-being. The first three are not surprising. One is exposure to poverty. Second is trauma. Third is discrimination. And fourth is
难怪我们的孩子表现出如此高且不断增长的抑郁、焦虑和药物使用水平。让我再补充一点。我记得昨天或前天，《变态心理学杂志》刚发表了一篇文章，关于抑郁症随时间增长的趋势。虽然所有社会人口群体都有所增加，但我了解到，增幅最大、上升最陡峭的是最高收入水平的青年。换句话说，来自最富裕家庭的青少年是随着时间推移抑郁症状水平上升最快的人群。所以这不是我们想象出来的。这是一组发现。另一份报告是由罗伯特·伍德·约翰逊基金会发布的，他们列出了危害青少年福祉的四大环境。前三个并不令人惊讶。一是贫困，二是创伤，三是歧视，第四是
excessive pressures to achieve, usually seen in affluent, not always, but usually seen in affluent communities. So this is not something that we are imagining. This is not a one-town phenomenon or an East Coast phenomenon. This is it generalizes to upper middle class upwardly mobile, well-educated families
过度的成就压力，通常出现在富裕社区，虽然不总是，但通常出现在富裕社区。所以这不是我们想象出来的。这不是一个城镇的现象，也不是东海岸的现象。这在全国各地的中上层、向上流动、受过良好教育的家庭中普遍存在。
all over the country. This is not just the Uber rich. So what advice do you have for parents in this situation when they're faced with mounting pressures from all sides? So I have advice for parents, but even before we go there, I want to underscore one more time,
这不仅仅是超级富豪。那么，对于处于这种情况、面临四面八方不断增加压力的家长，你有什么建议吗？所以我对家长有建议，但在我们谈论那个之前，我想再次强调，
let's stop parents blaming. You know, the truth is those of us who've had the good fortune of attending good colleges and universities, it's not unnatural for parents to want the same for their children, right? You agree with me? Oh, yeah, absolutely, of course. Right. So what advice do I have for parents? My advice is, by all means, strive for the best, aim for the best you can for your children. help them pursue whatever activities and academic activities and extracurriculars that they want to.
让我们停止指责家长。你知道，事实是，我们这些有幸进入好大学和好大学的人，家长希望自己的孩子也一样，这并不反常，对吧？你同意我吗？哦，是的，当然，绝对同意。对。那么我对家长有什么建议？我的建议是，无论如何，争取最好的，为你的孩子设定你能做到的最高目标。帮助他们追求他们想要的任何活动、学术活动和课外活动。
But be watchful for when they are getting too stressed, too anxious, burned out, and unhappy. Be watchful. At that point, it is important for you to say, sweetheart, is it time to drop it down a notch? Maybe there's something we need to pull back from, watch out for your child's seat. obviously. I know this is a hard thing to do because as a parents do want their kids to get ahead, but in this day and age, it's absolutely critical that we watch out for this. Stop with do more. Stop with this. You can, therefore you must. Stop with this. Just try harder. Yeah, I do want to focus a little bit on what I was talking about on the situation that came to light this week,
但要留意他们何时变得压力过大、焦虑、精疲力竭和不快乐。要留意。在那一点上，对你说“亲爱的，是时候放慢一点节奏了吗？”是很重要的。也许有些事情我们需要退后一步，显然要留意你孩子的状态。我知道这很难做到，因为作为家长确实希望孩子领先，但在当今时代，留意这一点绝对至关重要。停止“做得更多”。停止这种“你能做到，所以你必须做到”。停止这种“再努力一点”。是的，我确实想稍微关注一下我刚才谈到的本周曝光的情况，
which does focus on parents and coaches. Do you think the parents in the alleged scheme deprive their children have the chance to make important decisions for themselves? Going back to that first question I had about developing identity and autonomy. I think what the parents did was over the top. Obviously, it's illegal and it's corrupt. Having said that again, I raised my own kids in Westchester County, New York. They went through the same kind of pressure to achieve and accomplish. And truthfully, all of us parents do whatever we can to help our kids. Does that mean we're taking away a sense of control from them? Not necessarily. As I said, a lot of this becomes self-propelled. They do the extra AP course and the extra sport and so on, because somehow in their minds that one extra,
这确实集中在家长和教练身上。你认为涉嫌此事的家长剥夺了孩子为自己做出重要决定的机会吗？回到我关于发展认同感和自主性的第一个问题。我认为家长们所做的是过火了。显然，这是非法的，也是腐败的。话虽如此，我再次重申，我在纽约州威彻斯特县抚养我自己的孩子。他们经历了同样的成就和成功的压力。老实说，我们所有的家长都会尽我们所能帮助我们的孩子。这是否意味着我们剥夺了他们的控制感？不一定。正如我所说，很多事情变成了自我驱动。他们做额外的AP课程和额外的运动等等，因为在他们的脑海中，那多出来的一点点，
whatever it is, is going to make the hair's difference between acceptance or rejection from a college of their choice. So I'm not sure that parents are necessarily robbing their kids of a sense of control in this particular situation any more than all of us do. Am I, do you see what I'm saying? Yeah, absolutely. But I also want to understand, like, so why would failure be important for children and teens? I mean, we're facing these mounting pressures that he said, even things that were fun, like a sport or music becomes a chore because it's related to accolades and achievement and,
无论是什么，都将成为被他们选择的大学录取或拒绝之间的微小差别。所以我并不确定家长在这种情况下的做法，比我们所有人做的更多地剥夺了孩子的控制感。我，你明白我的意思吗？是的，绝对明白。但我还想了解，为什么失败对儿童和青少年很重要？我的意思是，我们正面临着你所说的这些不断增加的压力，甚至连曾经有趣的事情，比如运动或音乐，都变成了苦差事，因为它们与荣誉和成就有关，
you know, being the best going to stay. championships, that sort of thing. But as a psychologist, why do you think it's, why do you think it's important for teens and children to experience failure at some level in their lives? I think it's important for teens and children to experience failure just like it is for us. That said, once again, it's not clear to me that they don't. It's really not clear to me that they don't. As I said, I see this generation of kids as being humongous, terribly overworked. And if they are striving to be on that lacrosse team and a starter on the field hockey team, and the number of things they set themselves up to do, and these are high-level things,
你知道，成为最好的，参加州锦标赛，诸如此类的事情。但作为一名心理学家，你为什么认为青少年和儿童在生活中经历某种程度的失败很重要？我认为青少年和儿童经历失败很重要，就像对我们一样。话虽如此，再一次，我不清楚他们是否没有经历。我真的不清楚他们是否没有经历。正如我所说，我认为这一代孩子被过度劳累了，非常糟糕地过度劳累了。如果他们努力进入那个长曲棍球队，成为曲棍球队的首发队员，以及他们为自己设定的事情的数量，而且这些都是高水平的事情，
they do experience failures. They have to. And what do you think this situation shows us about meritocracy? Do you think there is a meritocracy out there, or is there a lack of it where you achieve based on what your, and your skills and abilities, as opposed to perhaps having access to more resources and that sort of thing. There's no question that having access to more resources tips the balance in your favor. Just even the system of legacies.
他们确实会经历失败。他们必须经历。你认为这种情况向我们展示了关于精英管理制度的什么？你认为存在一种精英管理制度，还是缺乏这种制度，即你的成就是基于你的技能和能力，而不是可能拥有更多的资源等等。毫无疑问，拥有更多的资源会使平衡向你倾斜。仅仅是校友优先录取制度，
It's just one example of how things. Legacies and athletics. It's flummoxers one to think that just because you play a sport, your chances of getting to top-nought school are better. Why not? Because you're a champion chess player or a beautiful vice. violinist. There are some inequities and some things that just don't make very good sense in terms of how admissions are structured and not entirely fair. So do you think this shows that education
这只是事情如何运作的一个例子。校友优先录取和体育特长。仅仅因为你参加了一项运动，你进入顶尖学校的机会就更好，这让人感到困惑。为什么不是因为你是国际象棋冠军或美丽的副小提琴手呢？在招生结构方面存在一些不平等和一些根本说不通的事情，而且并不完全公平。所以你认为这表明教育
does not necessarily resolve societies and equities because there's always people coming at different levels. I mean, you study teens and adults, I'm sorry, children and teens and poverty and also teens and children who are from affluent families. I think the inequities, in our society currently do play into this. I think what our young people are feeling now is that if I don't make the same level of money that my parents do, then I'm somehow going to be left behind. So young people are aspiring to have the same education experiences, careers, and standard of living that their parents did, do.
并不一定能解决社会的不平等，因为总是有来自不同阶层的人。我的意思是，你研究贫困的儿童和青少年，也研究来自富裕家庭的青少年和儿童。我认为我们社会目前的不平等确实在其中起作用。我认为我们的年轻人现在感觉到的是，如果我赚不到和我父母一样多的钱，那么我就会以某种方式被抛在后面。所以年轻人渴望拥有与他们父母曾经拥有、正在拥有的相同的教育经历、职业和生活水平。
And the truth is that it is, in fact, much more difficult to do that in today's day and age, economics, globalization, and so on. So what's happening is that these young people are feeling like, unless I get into that school, which is essential if I'm going to get into a high-paying job, my life is over. And someone asked me the other day, so why do they feel that? do they really feel like if they had a job as a teacher or, you know, something that is truly middle class, not top-notch, Wall Street or finance or, do they really feel like they can't survive? And the answer is, to some degree, yes, because there are teachers who have to talk about taking a second job as an Uber driver and so on to pay off the mortgage and, you know, see their kids through school and college and so on. So there is these extremes, I think, really have exacerbated this feeling of you cannot survive and lead a comfortable life. We're not talking about being rich if you don't somehow make it to that top 10, 20% of income levels. Do you think those feelings are perpetuated by what we see in news stories and everything?
事实是，在当今时代，经济、全球化等等，要做到这一点实际上要困难得多。所以发生的事情是，这些年轻人觉得，除非我进入那所学校，如果我要进入一份高薪工作，这至关重要，否则我的生活就完了。前几天有人问我，为什么他们会有这种感觉？他们真的觉得如果他们有一份老师的工作，或者，你知道，真正属于中产阶级的工作，而不是顶尖的、华尔街或金融业的工作，他们真的觉得他们无法生存吗？答案是，在某种程度上，是的，因为有老师不得不谈论做第二份工作，比如优步司机等等，来偿还抵押贷款，你知道，供他们的孩子上学和大学等等。所以我认为这些极端情况确实加剧了这种感觉：如果你不能以某种方式进入那前10%、20%的收入水平，你就无法生存并过上舒适的生活。我们不是在谈论变得富有。你认为这些感觉是被我们在新闻报道和一切中看到的东西所延续的吗？
Because there's a lot of stories saying, you know, this generation won't do as well as the previous generation parents. So, you know, young people coming up today in the job market are never going to achieve the same financial wealth or security as their parents. Do you think what do you think that does? I mean, is involving us, getting this involved in this whole conversation. What do you think being constantly bombarded with those messages does to us as a society? Yes, I like your phrase constantly bombarded. It is all over the news media. And back to what I was saying earlier, it's the news media, it's parents, it's their schools, you know, start getting.
因为有很多报道说，你知道，这一代人不会像上一代父母那样做得好。所以，你知道，今天进入就业市场的年轻人永远不会获得与他们父母相同的经济财富或保障。你认为这会造成什么影响？我的意思是，参与我们，卷入整个对话。你认为不断被这些信息轰炸对我们作为一个社会有什么影响？是的，我喜欢你用的“不断轰炸”这个词。新闻媒体到处都是。回到我刚才说的，是新闻媒体，是家长，是他们的学校，你知道，开始在
tract and middle school with the area of we have to get your resume as fancy and as impressive as possible, little 12-year-olds, you know, starting from there, if not earlier. And then that the university is talking about how selective they are, that doesn't help anything. So no, by rates have gone down from, well, 10% or 7%. That doesn't help anything. And the message is also that sometimes universities put out tacitly or otherwise that you I'm here and you're on the path to something really grand once you graduate. So it is truly is a message that youngsters and we as parents as we're trying to raise our
初中阶段就有了“我们必须让你的简历尽可能华丽和令人印象深刻”的领域，12岁的小孩子，你知道，从那里开始，如果不是更早的话。然后大学谈论他们有多挑剔，这没有任何帮助。所以不，录取率从10%降到7%。这没有任何帮助。而且大学有时含蓄地或以其他方式传达的信息是，你，我在这里，你一旦毕业就走在通往非常宏伟的道路上。所以这确实是年轻人，以及我们作为家长在试图抚养我们的
kids through their schooling and college are getting pretty much on a constant basis. Yeah, absolutely. And what do you think needs to change? I mean, what do you see that we need to do to make this a better situation, just less stress for everyone. Well, I mentioned one, Caitlin, that as parents that we can be watchful for levels and levels of depression, anxiety, stress, and reach out to our kids. And of course, adolescence is a time when they want to brush you off.
孩子完成学业和大学的过程中，几乎在持续不断地接收到的信息。是的，绝对是。你认为需要改变什么？我的意思是，你认为我们需要做什么来使这种情况变得更好，对每个人来说压力更小。嗯，我提到了一个，凯特琳，作为家长，我们可以留意抑郁、焦虑、压力的水平，并向我们的孩子伸出援手。当然，青春期是他们想要把你推开的时期。
And they do. That's developmentally appropriate. But don't give up if you feel your child is struggling. I would say the same for schools. counselors, teachers, academic teachers, be watchful for a child is getting burnt out. Put a cap on how many AP courses you can take or how many sports you can do. I was talking to a young girl at an independent school a couple of weeks ago. And she said, my God, if only the school said you can't take more than four APs,
他们确实会这样做。这在发展上是适当的。但如果你觉得你的孩子在挣扎，不要放弃。对于学校，我会说同样的话。辅导员、老师、学术老师，要留意孩子是否精疲力竭。限制你可以参加的AP课程数量或你可以参加的运动数量。几周前，我和一所私立学校的一个小女孩谈话。她说，天哪，如果学校说你不能参加超过四门AP课程，
just the fact that I can, I feel like I have to. So this is all of us have to come together. And, you know, my work is on resilience. That's something I've studied for the last 30 years among families and kids facing stresses of all kinds. And what we've learned about resilience is one, the single most important thing is that resilience rests on relationships. And that is something that is so threatened, so falling by the wayside for so many of our adolescents today, partly because they have no time. They're rushing from pillar to post in a frenzied fashion, partly because of social media where comparisons are constant, you know, formal. People's, other people's lives are better than mine.
仅仅因为我可以，我就觉得我必须这样做。所以这一切都需要我们所有人共同努力。而且，你知道，我的工作是关于韧性的。这是我在过去30年里在面临各种压力的家庭和孩子中研究的东西。关于韧性，我们学到的一点是，最重要的一点是，韧性建立在关系之上。而这对于我们当今如此多的青少年来说，是如此受到威胁，如此被抛在脑后，部分原因是他们没有时间。他们以一种疯狂的方式从一个地方赶到另一个地方，部分原因是社交媒体，在那里比较是持续不断的，你知道，正式的。别人的生活比我的好。
And partly because of competition with each other. If you think about it, adolescents, you know, we used to bond across over activities that we shared. Now you've got these two kids on the lacrosse team who are both being looked at from the scout. that's coming from X or Y University. And these kids are competing for the same things. And there is that frenzied sense of, my goodness, I have to get this at all costs. All these factors come together in fracturing what should have been a close-net, kids confiding in each other, supporting each other, being loving and helpful to each other.
部分原因是彼此之间的竞争。如果你想一想，青少年，你知道，我们过去通过我们分享的活动来建立联系。现在你有这两个长曲棍球队的孩子，他们都受到来自X或Y大学的球探的关注。这些孩子在为同样的事情竞争。有一种疯狂的感觉，天哪，我不惜一切代价必须得到这个。所有这些因素结合在一起，破坏了本应是亲密的、孩子们互相倾诉、互相支持、互相爱护和帮助的关系。
All of that is getting affected in a terrible way by this, well, well, I must succeed. succeed. I have to get a head at all costs. I have to beat everybody. I have to be ahead of everybody. So you said several times during the interview that it's not all about the parents, it's about the culture. And we've talked about the larger issues we're facing it at hand. But, you know, I would imagine that it's very easy for a parent to get caught up in, in this feeling that they have to do everything for their child. Their child has to be successful. And they have to, out of love and, you know, caring for their child, they have that they have to do what they can. So what are your comments about that about how parents can maybe help themselves not to get so pulled into that mentality?
所有这一切都受到了这种“好吧，我必须成功”的严重影响。成功。我不惜一切代价必须领先。我必须打败所有人。我必须领先于所有人。所以你在采访中多次提到，这不仅仅是关于家长，而是关于文化。我们已经讨论了我们面临的更大的问题。但是，你知道，我想象家长很容易陷入这种感觉，即他们必须为孩子做一切。他们的孩子必须成功。出于对孩子的爱和关心，他们必须尽其所能。那么你对家长如何帮助自己不被卷入那种心态有什么评论？
That's such an excellent question. The truth says, Caitlin, that it becomes a cultural norm. And if you decide that you're going to be, you know, you're going to opt out and say, well, I'm not doing the travel sports or I'm not doing X or Y. You are an oddball. If you say, I'm not getting the SAT teacher or the health for my child, you are an odd ball. And there are a couple of things that happen. First of all, you feel very isolated, typically, in this community. And secondly, I think parents start to question themselves.
这是一个非常好的问题。事实是，凯特琳，它变成了一种文化规范。如果你决定你要，你知道，你要选择退出，说，好吧，我不参加旅行运动，或者我不做X或Y。你就是一个怪人。如果你说，我不给我的孩子找SAT老师或帮助，你就是一个怪人。有几件事会发生。首先，你通常在这个社区感到非常孤立。其次，我认为家长开始质疑自己。
Is this wise? If the whole 10th grade or 12th grade is doing this, what am I doing to my child? So there is a sense of worry. And somebody used this phrase the other day, it's like lemmings. We all get caught up in this. you know, in the sense of, I wrote this paper, I can, therefore I must. That applies to the kids.
这明智吗？如果整个10年级或12年级都在这样做，我是在对我的孩子做什么？所以有一种担忧感。前几天有人用了这个短语，就像旅鼠一样。我们都被卷入了其中。你知道，在某种意义上，我写了这篇论文，我能做到，所以我必须做到。这适用于孩子们。
It applies to the parents. And we're all living in communities where there are norms. Those norms affect how we live. Somebody has to say the emperor has no clothes. And fortunately, we are now with the research that we're doing, I go into communities. I talk with whole parent bodies, with the entire faculty, with the students. and that is slowly leading parents and kids and communities to the point of saying,
它适用于家长。我们都生活在有规范的社区中。这些规范影响着我们的生活方式。必须有人说“皇帝没穿衣服”。幸运的是，我们现在正在进行研究，我进入社区。我和整个家长群体、全体教职员工、学生交谈。这正在慢慢引导家长、孩子和社区达到一种说
this is not working. We are looking at the data on our own kids. This is not working. And it starts with a small group of parents and then grows. There was a lovely show done by Alison Aubrey on NPR just a few months ago on the town of Wilton, Connecticut, where based on the data they saw on their own kids, they have really got mobilized a movement through their youth council with the school to dial back some of these things, to be more vigilant. As the one of the moms said, she said, if our school had
这行不通。我们正在查看我们自己孩子的数据。这行不通。它始于一小群家长，然后不断壮大。几个月前，艾莉森·奥布里在NPR上做了一个可爱的节目，关于康涅狄格州的威尔顿镇，基于他们从自己孩子身上看到的数据，他们通过青年委员会与学校真正发起了一场运动，以减少其中一些事情，更加警惕。正如其中一位妈妈所说，她说，如果我们的学校有
an outbreak of a serious physical illness, we'd be all over it. So why are we not doing this when we're watching these high levels of depression and anxiety? It's a long answer to your question, But yes, parents get swept up in this because it's the, in quotes, it's what we do is the way we live in our community. Slowly, slowly, patiently and gently, based on rigorous data, we are trying to say, let's dial this back just a little bit. There's another very important thing we need to consider. In fact, this may be the first order of business, which is that the parents themselves have to be replenished. and taken care of, if you will. A couple of years ago, my colleague Nancy Eisenberg and I did a special issue for this
一种严重的身体疾病爆发，我们都会全力以赴。那么，当我们看到这些高水平的抑郁和焦虑时，为什么我们不这样做呢？这是一个对你问题的长回答，但是是的，家长被卷入其中，因为它是，引用一下，这是我们所做的，是我们社区的生活方式。慢慢地、耐心地、温和地，基于严谨的数据，我们正试图说，让我们稍微减少一点。我们还需要考虑另一件非常重要的事情。事实上，这可能是第一要务，那就是家长自己必须得到补充。
journal Child Development. And the question we asked 11 sets of contributors was, if there was one thing that you want to change to benefit or help children who are facing adversities of various kinds, what would that be? And the single most consistent answer was, ensure the well-being of the primary caregiver, who's usually the mom. And the way that is done is by making sure the mom gets supportive. So in child development research, we're so used to thinking about parents and moms,
如果可以的话，得到照顾。几年前，我和我的同事南希·艾森伯格为这本《儿童发展》杂志做了一期特刊。我们问11组撰稿人的问题是，如果有一件事你想改变来造福或帮助面临各种逆境的儿童，那会是什么？最一致的回答是，确保主要照顾者的福祉，通常是妈妈。而实现这一目标的方法是确保妈妈得到支持。所以在儿童发展研究中，我们习惯于思考家长和妈妈，
but what we should do, what we shouldn't do, what we do, what we don't do. But almost never stop to ask the question, how do moms even do this with the ongoing demands and challenges and stresses? So a big factor that I, when I talk to parents and communities say, ensure that you are yourself taken care of. People say, telling moms to take better care of themselves. And I said, no. I'm not adding one more thing to the already very longness.
我们应该做什么，我们不应该做什么，我们做什么，我们不做什么。但几乎从不停止问这个问题，妈妈们在持续的需求、挑战和压力下是如何做到这一点的？所以我与家长和社区交谈时，一个很大的因素是，确保你自己得到照顾。人们说，告诉妈妈们更好地照顾自己。我说，不。我没有在已经很长的清单上再增加一件事。
What I'm saying is understand and understand the need for you to be tended yourself and prioritize. Make that. Make that happen. And in your research and your work, can you talk about what you see about the different pressures for children and teens? in poverty versus children and teens and affluent families. So this is an interesting couple of papers that came out of Boston, my colleagues in Boston, Rebecca Coley and Eric Dearing. They did analyses of large data sets, one of the U.S. and one in Norway, and essentially
我所说的是理解并理解你需要被照顾的需求，并优先考虑。让它发生。在你的研究和工作中，你能谈谈你对贫困儿童和青少年与富裕家庭儿童和青少年所面临的不同压力的看法吗？所以这是波士顿出来的几篇有趣的论文，我的波士顿同事丽贝卡·科利和埃里克·迪林。他们对大型数据集进行了分析，一个在美国，一个在挪威，本质上
showed a U-shaped link between school-level affluence and adjustment problems among teens, especially adolescents. And so what that means is there are elevated problems at both ends of community-level affluence. It's the kids in the poorest areas and kids in the most affluent communities that are showing higher levels of problems than those in the middle. Now, people will say, oh, why would that be? There's no question that living in poverty has enormous stresses ranging from violence on the streets to just not having enough food. to be able to survive. On the flip side, you have these specials that we've been talking about
显示了学校层面的富裕程度与青少年，特别是青少年调整问题之间的U型联系。所以这意味着在社区层面的富裕程度的两端都有升高的心理问题。在最贫困地区的孩子和最富裕社区的孩子表现出的问题水平比中间的孩子更高。现在，人们会说，哦，为什么会这样？毫无疑问，生活在贫困中有着巨大的压力，从街头的暴力到仅仅没有足够的食物来生存。另一方面，你有我们一直在谈论的这些压力
among families and kids in relatively affluent communities where there is this, the word that I keep using is this frenzied pursuit and this panic about, oh my goodness, if I don't do this, if I don't do that, I'm going to get left behind. And that applies as much to the parents as it does to the kids. That is not a good way to live. There's never a break. There's never a time when the kids can sit back and say, ah, the next week I'm going to do nothing, but chill.
在相对富裕社区的家庭和孩子中，存在这种，我一直使用的词是这种疯狂的追求和这种恐慌，哦，天哪，如果我不这样做，如果我不做那个，我就会被抛在后面。这不仅适用于家长，也适用于孩子。这不是一种好的生活方式。从来没有休息。从来没有一个时间，孩子们可以坐下来，说，啊，下周我要什么都不做，只是放松。
Yeah, it seems almost crazy to say that how loud, you know, to do nothing. What does that mean? I actually asked, I was in an old boy school not that long ago where, again, we've consistently seen these high levels of depression and stress. And I asked these boys, I had the luxury of sitting on and talking with them right after we did their question as. So I said, so are you happy? And they looked at me and said, what do you mean?
是的，说“什么都不做”听起来几乎很疯狂。那是什么意思？我实际上问过，不久前我在一所男校，在那里，我们再次持续地看到了这些高水平的抑郁和压力。我问这些男孩，我有幸在做完问卷后坐下来和他们交谈。所以我说，那么你们快乐吗？他们看着我说，你是什么意思？
What do you mean by happy? So I said, oh, I don't know. Do you ever feel but chill out and relaxed? And they truthfully looked at me and says, we don't do that. It's very telling. So even their parties, right? So you said, do they get together? Yes, they do.
你说的快乐是什么意思？所以我说，哦，我不知道。你有没有感到放松和悠闲的时候？他们老实地看着我说，我们不那样做。这非常能说明问题。所以即使是他们的派对，对吧？所以你说，他们聚在一起吗？是的，他们聚在一起。
Even their parties have become so, once again, frenzied. There's drugs and alcohol at most of these social gatherings. In fact, it's rare to have one, but there isn't a keg or some kind of substance that's being passed around. So even that is high octane. Hurry up and enjoy yourself. You hear about pre-gaming where kids will have a few swigs of vodka or whatever, even before they get to the party so they can be relaxed enough to truly enjoy themselves. So worse in a generation ago, perhaps, yes, we had a drink or two. to chill and have fun, there's a sense, a greater sense now of drinking to get drunk,
即使是他们的派对也变得如此，再一次，疯狂。在大多数这些社交聚会上都有毒品和酒精。事实上，很少有不提供啤酒桶或某种正在传递的物质的派对。所以即使是那样也是高强度的。快点享受你自己。你听说过“预热”，孩子们在去派对之前会喝几口伏特加或什么，这样他们就能足够放松，真正享受自己。所以比一代人前可能更糟，是的，我们喝了一两杯来放松和玩乐，现在有一种更大的感觉，为了喝醉而喝酒，
as opposed to a laid back and fun. And are you following what I'm saying? Yes, absolutely. And I think, you know, to summarize our conversation today, we really, really talking about, yes, this story is in the news and it's very sensational. There's a lot of elements to it. It's shocking on many levels. It's upsetting.
而不是悠闲和有趣。你明白我的意思吗？是的，绝对明白。而且我认为，你知道，总结我们今天的谈话，我们真的，真的在谈论，是的，这个故事在新闻中，它非常耸人听闻。它有很多元素。它在许多层面上令人震惊。它令人不安。
It's causing a lot of people to be angry. We're also saying this is an extreme example, a symptom of a larger societal issue we're all facing. Very well said. I'd say it's the tip of an iceberg that is really quite big and spreads across a pretty wide swath of America and the world. It's the top 20, 25, 30 percent. Everybody's who's aspiring to maintain the standard of living and wants their kids to get a good education, it spreads across all of us. And then it really takes starting small, with small pockets of people to help change this, change what we're seeing because we are seeing now the effects of our young people today with depression, substance abuse. Yeah.
它导致很多人感到愤怒。我们也在说这是一个极端的例子，是我们所有人面临的更大社会问题的一个症状。说得非常好。我会说这是冰山的一角，它确实相当大，并蔓延到美国和世界相当广泛的范围。这是前20%、25%、30%。每个人都渴望维持生活水平，并希望他们的孩子接受良好的教育，它蔓延到我们所有人身上。然后它确实需要从小处着手，从小群人开始，帮助改变这一点，改变我们所看到的，因为我们现在看到了我们当今年轻人抑郁、药物滥用的影响。是的。
Caitlin, think about the cigarette smoking and how that changed around and rates went down a few decades ago. Big part of that was research and evidence again and again showing there are risks associated. and here's what they are. In the same way, we take the same approach with our research with highly achieving schools, is to keep at it and document again and again and again across schools, independent schools, public schools, day schools, boarding schools, in cities and suburbs, east coast, west coast, down south, Midwest. Everywhere we go, we're seeing the same problem. And it's documenting it in peer-reviewed research journals and bringing those data back to communities, the general data and the data on their own school saying, all right, folks,
凯特琳，想想香烟吸烟以及几十年前它是如何改变的，比率下降了。其中很大一部分是研究和证据一次又一次地表明存在相关的风险。这就是它们是什么。同样，我们在高成就学校的研究中采取同样的方法，就是坚持下去，一次又一次地在学校、独立学校、公立学校、走读学校、寄宿学校、城市和郊区、东海岸、西海岸、南方、中西部记录。无论我们走到哪里，我们都看到了同样的问题。并将其记录在同行评审的研究期刊中，并将这些数据带回社区，一般数据和他们自己学校的数据，说，好吧，各位，
here's what it is. That does propel some movement forward, maybe slow, but there is definitely a beginning movement to say we need to take this very, very seriously. Yeah, absolutely. Thank you so much for being on the show, Dr. Luther. I really appreciate your time. It's my pleasure, Caitlin. We love to hear from our listeners.
这就是情况。这确实推动了一些进展，也许缓慢，但绝对有一个开始的运动，说我们需要非常、非常认真地对待这一点。是的，绝对是。非常感谢您参加节目，路德博士。我真的很感谢你的时间。这是我的荣幸，凯特琳。我们喜欢听取听众的意见。
So if you have any questions, comments, or ideas to share, you can email me at K-Luna at APA.org. that's KLUNA at APA.org. Also, please consider giving us a rating in iTunes. We'd really appreciate it. Speaking of Psychology is part of the APA podcast network, which includes the podcast's APA journals dialogue about new psychological research and progress notes about the practice of psychology.
所以如果你有任何问题、评论或想法要分享，你可以发电子邮件给我，地址是K-Luna@APA.org。那是KLUNA@APA.org。此外，请考虑在iTunes上给我们评分。我们将非常感激。《心理学谈话》是APA播客网络的一部分，其中包括播客“APA期刊对话”关于新的心理学研究，以及“进度记录”关于心理学实践。
You can find all our podcasts on iTunes, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts. You can also go to our website, speakingof psychology.org to listen to more episodes. I'm Caitlin Luna with the American Psychological Association. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在iTunes、Stitcher或任何你获取播客的地方找到我们所有的播客。你也可以访问我们的网站speakingofpsychology.org收听更多剧集。我是美国心理学会的凯特琳·卢纳。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。